[Musique]
j'ai réglé le problème c'est quoi ça ces
belles les rapides elle est maligne et
elle sait conduire écoute on peut pas y
arriver à trois nous faut un chauffeur
c'est pas chez toi ici demande lui de
partir je suis là vous pouvez me parler
je vous connais pas c'est pas la peine
mais je peux m'en allais n'ai pas de
souci à temps il nous faut un chauffeur
vous avez envie de partager votre pas
pourquoi la nôtre quatre parts égales ou
rien tu t'emportes 40
j'ai pas besoin de garanties il nous
faut un autre flingue
j'ai le mien et figure pas comment tu me
parles si tu restes des faucons de brive
tout de suite
vous ne savez rien c'est ça ou vous avez
choisi de ne rien savoir
[Musique]
votre mari m'a volé deux millions de
dollars
[Musique]
des sachets de ma fille
il s'agit de ma fille
et puisqu'il s'agit de ma vie maintenant
il s'agit de la vôtre
[Musique]
il s'est passé quelque chose cette
limite quelque chose de terrible
monsieur l'icann votre famille faisait
partie de la vie de harry depuis très
longtemps j'ai besoin d'aidé je vois pas
ce que je peux faire
nos maris ne reviendront pas
on est tout seul
mon mari m'a laissé les plans de son
prochain qu as tu besoin d'une équipe
pour aller jusqu'au bout pourquoi on
devrait le faire confiance parce que je
suis votre seul rempart contre une balle
dans la tête
ce que les hommes comme votre mari et
mon père
on appris
c'est qu'on récolte ce qu'on sème
espérons le
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour les flingues mes fringues que
je trouverai où tu trouveras
si ça tourne mal je veux que mes enfants
sachent que je me suis pas laissé faire
g h i
notre meilleur atout c'est d'être qui
nous sommes
pourquoi parce que personne ne s'imagine
qu'on va avoir les couilles d'aller
jusqu'au bout